you have to be incredibly fit these
actors put in some serious work at the
gym transforming into a superhero is
easier said than done find out the
extreme diets and workout regimens it
takes to be a hero in the mcu training
for
about six or eight months for that first
film it takes a lot of hard work for
chris hemsworth to maintain the god of
thunder's impressive physique the
workouts he does include working on his
core kickboxing and even surfing one of
hemsworth's favorite hobbies his trainer
luke zaki stated that the majority of
the work they do is done months before
the movies to ensure hemsworth is camera
ready chris is so strong that when zaki
holds the pads for hemsworth to kick he
has to brace himself because chris is
powerful enough to knock him down like
i'd rather sort of feel good and look
that extra bit you know when kumail
nanjiani was cast as kingo in the
eternals fans wondered how the comedian
would translate to a superhero role he
answered with a shirtless picture on
instagram that showed off his new
physique this impressive transformation
was a result of a full year of work
nanjiani stated his strict diet was the
hardest part as he didn't eat any
refined sugar and almost no carbs for a
year the hard work clearly paid off
though as his new look even garnered
praise from dwayne johnson he said uh
dense muscle is hard to achieve my
brother he thinks my muscle is dense
before guardians of the galaxy pratt was
known as the schlubby comedian on parks
and rec but quickly proved he was much
more pratt lost 60 pounds in six months
working three or four hours a day of
just consistent ass kicking hard work
trainer duffy gaver had nothing but
praise for pratt's work ethic and
commitment he isn't the client you have
to push he's the type of client you have
to pull down with guardians of the
galaxy 3 coming up next we're sure pratt
will be hard at work again the secret is
you can't do it
in a month robert downey jr has been
training with wing chun a technique made
famous by bruce lee since 2003. when it
came time to play tony stark downey kept
this in his regimen as well as adding
kung fu qigong and strength training his
trainer brad bose made it his focus to
increase downey's muscle we cut way back
on cardio and really increased the
weight he was lifting down he was able
to add on 25 pounds of muscle after
months of work and consuming 5 000
calories a day five years ago what used
to be my get in shape plan is moot and
useless renner had some experience with
getting in shape before his turn as
clint barton in the mcu and carried over
that work ethic to get in shape for
hawkeye he posted himself lifting some
weights in preparation for his role in
the disney plus series hawkeye in terms
of sharpening his archery skills renner
has actually trained with olympic
archers for the films but it apparently
isn't as helpful as you might think um
got pretty good at it actually but it
doesn't really serve me too for for
hawkeye stuff evans put in a ton of work
to attain his super soldier body for the
first movie evans went to the gym four
to five days a week for three months
training for about two hours a day
working with trainer simon waterson
evans was able to get his body fat down
to eight percent while working on civil
war the hardest part for evans was the
amount of food he had to consume as well
as the kind of food just bland naked
pieces of chicken and rice and it's it's
it's not that appetizing
when johansson got the role of black
widow she admitted that she had never
stepped foot in a gym before that
quickly changed however johansen and her
trainer eric johnson agreed to focus on
strength and functional movements not
looks it took about a year to reach her
desired fitness goals and she has kept
it up for all her marvel movies i am
stronger and more capable now than i was
10 years ago which is so awesome to be
able to say fit in my everyday life i
like to feel strong it's part of my
mental well-being the late chadwick
boseman already had a martial arts
background when he was cast as the black
panther his trainer addison henderson
focused on non-stop training that had
bozeman constantly moving working out up
to four hours a day it was an intense
experience for bozeman fight training
conditioning eating a certain amount it
was hardcore basically it was like
training like a fighter you know tom
holland was one of the most athletic and
fit actors coming into his mcu role
bringing with him a background in
gymnastics and dancing for spider-man
holland started boxing and going to the
gym every morning for about an hour with
his trainer i look up i look up to
boxers a lot he also did ems training
where he wore a suit with pads that
would send electrical shocks through his
muscles it's a lot of fun and it works
but it really is the worst thing i've
ever done sebastian stan admitted that
at the time of getting the role he
didn't know his body well or whether his
diet was good or not it was the first
thing he and his trainer addressed as
they figured out what routine and diet
was best for him stan was often in the
gym starting every session with a heavy
lift he discussed the effects his
workouts have on him it's gonna motivate
you to be more
driven in the other aspects of your life
brie larson was the first female
superhero to lead her own movie in the
mcu so she wanted to prove that she
belonged right alongside the rest of the
avengers she did 9 months of training in
total sometimes doing her sessions five
times a week her trainer jason walsh
praised her effort she did the work
nutrition recovery sleep everything
required of her larsen can now do some
seriously impressive feats of strength
including a one-armed pull-up and
pushing a 5 000 pound jeep it's been a
really powerful journey for me to learn
what my body can do paul rudd is much
like chris pratt in that when he joined
the mcu he was known for being a
not-too-fit comedic actor that all
changed when he got in shape for his
role as ant-man rudd was motivated to
get in shape as he wanted to get into
the mindset of his character and really
fit the part i figured if i'm in really
good shape i will feel like less of an
imposter in the role the hard work paid
off but rudd said it meant not doing
anything fun for a year basically made
health and fitness the focus of my day
to prepare for her role as mantis palm
clementiev didn't take the traditional
route her co-stars did to get in shape
all her work was practical consisting of
stunt and fight training in one video
she can be seen doing sit-ups while
hanging off of a punching bag
maintaining a healthy diet is a
difficulty for clementiev when she tries
to cut something out she becomes
obsessed with it for me it's about
quantity balance i eat a little bit of
everything when i had that the addition
had no idea how big the character would
be lily got in great shape for the
ant-man movies but revealed that she
suffers from chronic back pain she
stated she spent a good portion of the
last two years in bed as she had a
physical breakdown fortunately she seems
to be taking control of her body now as
she is focusing on foundation training
to rebuild her base she even posted a
picture of herself on twitter with the
caption
wasp ready arms signaling she is
prepared to portray the wasp again i was
asking to build a lot of these s curves
into her fight style cumberbatch did all
the traditional working out and dieting
to prepare for doctor strange you spend
months eating the right stuff doing the
right kind of press ups and pull-ups and
dips and all the other jazz he revealed
a strange technique he was taught to
look his best on camera it involved
dehydrating himself the night before and
then the day of shooting eating a rather
odd combination of foods you basically
are told to eat skittles and drink
coffee because it dehydrates you so
basically your skin then shrink wraps
around the muscle fiber we have nothing
but respect for the hard work and
dedication these actors put towards
getting into shape for their roles
maintaining a superhero physique is no
easy task but these actors were up to
the challenge which transformation did
you find most impressive